the Aaron store era at the present era
priests augerin of various reeks banks
priests economist reactance cop till
alfred nobel's mean it is a great honor
to introduce the laureate of the slurry
Riksbank prize in Economic Sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel
professor Angus Deaton
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
your excellencies laureates ladies and
gentlemen when I was a boy living in
Edinburgh in Scotland
especially in December when the hours of
daylight were few and it was cold and
often wet
I used the dream of escaping to a
tropical magical Kingdom I searched the
public libraries and museums for books
and objects about sunny warm and exotic
places reading was the magic carpet that
took me away from the cold and dark
little did I know that when the magical
day came as it did today it would indeed
be in a kingdom but one that was even
further north even colder and with even
fewer hours of daylight of course the
true magic kingdom that the wee boy
sought was inside his head inside books
and inside museums
I want to thank Sweden not only for this
magnificent honor but also for being a
kingdom that cares so much about
learning about intellectual pursuits and
about scientific achievement you are a
lantern of hope in a world where so much
of what we care about is under threat
I became an economist by accident with
little formal training an absence that
I'd regretted for many years but perhaps
I can stop regretting now I drifted from
one topic to another learning as I went
because I had not been taught I was free
not only of what I should have known but
also of at least some prejudices and
preconceptions along the way I was
helped by distinguished mentors several
of whom have stood here before me and by
distinguished collaborators several of
whom are here tonight I have the great
good fortune that one of my
collaborators in work and case is also
my collaborator in life one of my
greatest pleasures in recent years as
being the seeing the subject matter of
economics broaden and expand it has not
given up its core themes its measurement
or its mathematics but it has reimbursed
its origins in history in psychology in
political science in sociology and in
philosophy it has become a richer and
more humane subject but this award is
also a great tribute to my tribe within
the tribe those of us who worried about
measurement about how to provide
coherent accounts of what we measure and
continue to work on one of the oldest
topics in economics the study of prices
of market behavior and of human welfare
thank you very much